wunderschönen guten tag bremen schön
großen privaten über uwe ich sage es ist
schön zu sein es ist toll diesen voll
platz hier zu sehen ist es schon
henning und klaus und jens hier zu sehen
aber liebe ersten eins kann ich jetzt
hier nicht machen
es geht einfach nicht ich kann jetzt
nicht sagen ich liebe bringen
ich kann das hier dieses livia die eifel
aber aber aber was ich überall in
deutschland liebe es wenn ich irgendwo
hinkomme und ich merke dir macht gut
regiert und ich sage euch nehmen wird
gut regiert und deswegen blieb ich
mitnehmen
also ich lebe auf die tasten meine frau
hat nichts dagegen
[Gelächter]
über wenn ich werde bremen gut regiert
dann ist das etwas was ich aus innerster
überzeugung sagen kann ich habe den
kassen erlebt wer bei den äußerst
schwierigen verhandlungen über die
zukunft der finanzbeziehungen zwischen
bund und ländern für bewegung richtig
gekämpft und richtig was rausgeholt hat
und ich sage euch das zelt das zelt in
den nächsten jahren weil bremen die gute
wirtschaftliche entwicklung so am besten
unterstützen kann und ich sage prämien
wird gut regiert weil die familien hier
bremen die kleine kinder haben massiv im
sommer entlastet werden durch
gebührenfreie kitas ich komme aus
rheinland pfalz oder was hamburg name
das schon gemacht ihr seid die nächsten
themen ist auch davon und ehrlich gesagt
ist bremen bundesweiten vorbildern ich
kenne keine andere stadt aus hamburg
muss ich sagen darf man hier sagen ja
man ist das ist der soziale wohnungsbau
bezahlbarer wohnraum ich habe die tür zu
tür mit kasten gemacht schon persönlich
und hat mir das angeguckt und ich sage
dir kasten
da können sich viele andere städte in
deutschland eine scheibe abschneiden
dass die primär gegen privatisierung
nicht standard dass sie
verbreitungsverbot besetzt sein
das ist super dass es gutes regieren
ja
jetzt will ich mal was sagen da gibt es
ja uns spitzenkandidaten der cdu
ich muss schon sagen der mann hat
rutscht sagt ich hab das noch nie
gemacht ich habe eigentlich keine ahnung
und ich will auch noch irgendwie stolz
drauf und dann kommt er oft ganz absurde
sachen der gute privatisierung
öffentlicher unternehmen ist er da für
wohnungsbau wie zb beim rennbahngelände
ist er dagegen
und wenn ganz deutschland sogar bei mir
in der lokalzeitung in der hinteren
alpha sich darüber empört wird dass man
der eiswette keine frauen zugelassen
werden sagt der mann
also dass frauen nicht zugelassen werden
finde ich okay finde ich nicht okay wir
haben schon genug probleme mit solchen
typen auf der ganzen welt
mehr bremen nicht
[Applaus]
wenn ich gar nicht okay ich sage euch
was es in diesen tagen braucht in
deutschland
was es in diesen tagen auch ihren brehm
braucht in bremerhaven das ist klar
heute klarheit wo man steht und ich sage
euch deswegen klipp und klar solange wir
auf dieser bühne stehen und für wahlen
werden sozialdemokratin sozialdemokraten
in ganz deutschland über 156 jahre haben
wir immer klar gestanden und klare kante
gegen rechts das ist das was uns
auszeichnet und deswegen sage ich euch
diese wahl ist wichtig am sonntag für
ganz europa aber auch hier verbringen
ja mal ganz im ernst leute die cdu hatte
geplant mit sebastian kurz heute den
wahlkampf abschluss zu machen
jetzt hat der mann ab gesagt er würde in
sien gebraucht das darf bezweifelt
werden
das darf bezweifelt werden aber wisst
ihr was ich wirklich aufregt warum haben
die denn überhaupt eingeladen der cut
strache zum vizekanzler in österreich
gemacht und das war von anfang an ein
ganz schlechter gedanke ein ganz
schlechter gedanke liebe genossinnen und
genossen meine damen und herren
[Musik]
die leute jahre könnte das gibt's mit
uns sozialdemokraten und zwar hier in
bremen auch in deutschland aber es gibt
es auch überall in europa frans
timmermans hat sich angelegt mit den
kaczynskis mit den bands und auch in
rumänien unabhängig vom parteibuch udo
wir haben da ganz klar mit franz
zimmermann jemand der die
rechtsstaatlichkeit in europa verteidigt
der die pressefreiheit verteidigt und
liebe leute es geht um nicht weniger als
dass diese rechtspopulisten mit verlaub
das rad zurückdrehen wollen
nationalismus neue schranken in den
köpfen an den straßen wollen wir nicht
deswegen es mit den vom vortag liebe
genossinnen und genossen meine damen und
herren
[Musik]
aber es geht nicht nur darum europa das
ist ein sensor sorgt für viele menschen
die von außen auf unseren teil der erde
gucken und ich frage sie alle wollten
sie leben wenn sie die freie wahl hätten
wenn sie sich entscheiden müssten wo auf
diesem planeten ich meine sich reisen
mal gucken wie es woanders ist ich meine
jetzt wirklich leben und ich glaube dass
sie antwort von den allermeisten hier
antwort wäre europa denn das ist der
einzige ort auf diesem planet mu wie
demokratie wirtschaft und
sozialstaatlichkeit noch einigermaßen
verteidigen können das ist es worum es
am sonntag in europa der sensor tochter
[Musik]
und
ich möchte nicht nur dass europa ein
sehnsuchtsort für die menschen ist die
von außen auf uns gucken nee nee nee nee
ich möchte dass europa ein sehnsucht
auch dafür alle europäerinnen und
europäer ist und wie frage ich sie
passend dazu ein euro 72 mindestlohn in
bulgarien
dafür kann man auch in bulgarien nicht
leben wir brauchen einen europäischen
mindestlohn einen lohn von dem jeder in
seinem land leben können
dafür steht die spd für ein sozialeres
europa damit es auch und so soll für
alle europäerinnen und europäer ist
[Musik]
und
wer wirklich will dass dieses europa
nicht geteilt ist in die die wenig haben
und deswegen hier arbeiten müssen für 34
euro die paketboten mein gott was sind
das für zustände
die werden ja ausgebeutet das ist
lohndumping zu unserer eigenen
arbeitnehmer und das ist unanständig
gegenüber denen und deswegen wollen wir
was wir wollen nicht dass europa stehen
bleiben so wie es ist reicht uns schon
ist genug europa nein wir wollen mehr
europa aber das richtige gruppe wir
wollen ein soziales europa und da sage
ich gucken sie sich an wer ist da
wirklich glaubwürdig das sind wir
sozialdemokraten das sind wir an dieser
stelle auch im inland der
glaubwürdigkeit in sozialen fragen das
heißt dass uns der werte arbeit dann am
ende auch was wert ist und das heißt für
mich dass leute die 35 jahre gearbeitet
haben am ende nach anständige rente
bekommen müssen ohne zum sozialamt gehen
zu müssen und dass es die grundrente für
die die spd stellt und wie wir auch
durchsetzen werden
[Musik]
aber der richtigkeit das ist nicht nur
sozialstaatlichkeit das ist auch
gerechte besteuerung und mit verlaub
hier um direkte bezahlt hier jeder jede
imbissbude bezahlte steuern amazon
google und facebook aber nicht und das
werden wir nicht länger hinnehmen auch
deswegen brauchen wir starkes europa und
den starken finanzminister und das ist
olaf scholz
er wird das durchsetzen in den nächsten
jahren eher als ist ganz einfach leute
wer hier geld verdient wer hier geld
verdient in europa in deutschland der
museumsscheune sein wer könne schon
sollte der kann ja auch kein geld
verdienen ist ganz ganz einfache sache
und deswegen ist es nicht einfach weil
wir in einstimmigkeitsprinzip haben auf
der europäischen ebene und deswegen war
es so schwierig dass sie zum ersten
rutsch durchzukriegen haben viel dagegen
gestimmt aber das kann ja noch werden
und wenn es nicht wird dann sage ich
hierzu dann machen wir es mit denen die
wollen und das ist die mehrheit in
europa deswegen wird es mit uns eine
gerechte besteuerung von konzernen in
europa geben
[Musik]
der ursprungsgedanke der europäischen
union was war das wissen sie alle
frieden habe heiko maas sie heute hier
ist kann das aus seiner eigenen
familiengeschichte noch viel besser
erklären an der grenze direkt frieden
und was passiert gerade alle rüsten auf
verbal mit drohgebärden mit gesten es
werden flugzeugträger verschifft
und deswegen ist es so wichtig dass
europa eine eigene eine eigene starke
eine friedens stimme auf diesem planeten
hat donald trump droht dem iran indirekt
mit krieg der iran droht zurück und in
diesem moment brauchen wir doch vor
allem eins abrüstung rhetorisch und
militärisch und dafür muss doch europa
stehen für abrüstung für frieden für
diplomatie und deswegen ich weiß nicht
was in den nächsten wochen und monaten
passiert aber ich sage ihnen sehr klar
mit uns sozialdemokraten wird es keine
deutsche beteiligung an irgendeiner
militärintervention interventionen im
iran geben mit uns sozialdemokraten nein
das sollen sich alle merken die auch nur
die leiseste fantasie haben dass wir dem
jemals zustimmen könnten das werden wir
nicht tun
[Musik]
jetzt ist der moment der entscheidung
es ist jetzt zeit sich zu entscheiden
wollen wir auf mehr zusammenarbeit in
europa setzen
oder wollen wir aber an bauland strache
und co dieses europa überlassen damit
sie es zerstören können so zugespitzt so
zugespitzt ist die situation in europa
und jede und jeder von ihnen hat es in
der hand mit ihrer stimme wir
sozialdemokraten waren und wir sind und
wir werden immer das bollwerk gegen
rechts sein für ein soziales europa mit
franz zimmermann seiner spitze mit einer
spitzenkandidatin katarina barley einer
europäerin vom scheitel bis zur sohle
wie man sie sich nicht besser wünschen
kann und wundervollen mann und sie alle
entscheiden und es ist eine doppelte
entscheidung ihren bremen das sage ich
natürlich nicht überall ist sehr klar
hier in bremen geht es doppel trumpf es
wird einmal darum dass bremen weiter
carsten sieling gut regiert wird dass es
meine feste überzeugung dass die
bremerinnen und bremer die
bremerhavenerin und bremerhavener das
verdient haben weiter gut sozial regiert
zu werden und deswegen wählt kassen
sieling und die spd in bremen
zirbel seine hand für ein soziales
europa für ein europa der weltoffenheit
der offenen grenzen und es ehrgeiz es
aus diesem sehnsuchtsort europa ein
weiteres gutes jahrhundert zu machen und
sie haben es in der hand hier in bremen
für ein weltoffenes für ein
verlässliches für vorbildliches prämien
zu wählen
ihre wahl ist aber deswegen auch ganz
einfach wählen sie spd vielen dank
[Applaus]